Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. In today's episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, I am joined by Mark
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天这期《有抱负的心理学家》播客中，Mark
Turnbull and we are discussing so many things that it might well be easier to tell you the things we're not covering. We are covering diabetes, being a slightly older applicant, being married, being a parent. We're talking motivational interviewing. We are talking so many useful themes. Stay tuned right to the end to get Mark's top tips for how to reduce burnout and how to be your most authentic self. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. I am told many times by people that they are worried they might be too old or that they want to get qualified and then have children after training. And I often
Turnbull加入了我的节目，我们讨论的内容非常广泛，甚至列出我们没谈到的内容可能更容易。我们讨论了糖尿病、作为大龄申请者、已婚身份、为人父母等话题。我们还谈到了动机访谈法，以及许多其他有用的主题。请务必听到最后，获取Mark关于如何减少职业倦怠以及如何展现最真实自我的顶级建议。你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是Marianne Trent博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。很多人经常告诉我，他们担心自己年纪太大，或者想在培训结束后再生孩子。我通常
respond in the same way, that there is no race, it's okay, it's all right to have a different start point to somebody else and that we all have different life experiences really which will affect our trajectory. But today we are talking with an incoming trainee clinical psychologist who has had quite a few adverse life experiences and who has so much useful stuff that we can learn from. And it was just such a pleasure speaking with him. And I hope you'll find it a really helpful listen. We would love to know what you think to this episode so please do let me know of any feedback that you have got. I'd also love it if you came and let me know in the free Facebook group which is the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr Marianne Trent. I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side. Hope you find this
会这样回答：人生不是赛跑，没关系，起点与他人不同是可以的，我们每个人都有不同的生活经历，这会影响我们的轨迹。但今天我们要采访的是一位即将入学的临床心理学实习生，他经历过不少逆境，但他身上有很多值得我们学习的宝贵经验。与他交谈真是太愉快了，希望你们也会觉得这期节目很有帮助。我们很想知道你对这期节目的看法，所以请务必告诉我你的反馈。如果你能加入我们的免费Facebook群组“Dr Marianne Trent的有抱负的心理学家社区”并告诉我你的想法，我会非常高兴。期待在节目之后与你交流。希望你觉得这期节目
useful. Hi, I just want to welcome along our guest for today, Mark Turnbull, who is an incoming trainee clinical psychologist. Welcome, Mark. Hello. Hi, thanks for having me. Oh, thanks for reaching out to me. You are another LinkedIn, a LinkedIn reacher outer. And we just sort of just chatting in the DMs, didn't't we so you'd contacted me to say how much you'd enjoyed the recent podcast episode with nikita um who's recently she's also an incoming trainee um but also to just highlight that other perspectives are equally as valid and that sometimes it we just take our own sweet time to get to the same destination and I really enjoyed our chats which have been voice voice notes largely um and yeah I said how about how about coming on
有用。你好，我想欢迎今天的嘉宾Mark Turnbull，他是一位即将入学的临床心理学实习生。欢迎你，Mark。你好。嗨，谢谢邀请我。哦，谢谢你主动联系我。你也是一位通过LinkedIn主动联系我的人。我们之前在私信里聊过，对吧？你联系我是为了说你有多喜欢最近那期关于Nikita的播客，她也是一位即将入学的实习生。你还强调了其他视角同样有效，有时我们只是需要花点时间才能到达同一个目的地。我真的很喜欢我们的聊天，大部分是语音留言，所以我说，要不要来
the podcast and talking to me and thankfully you were game yes um it's certainly a challenging experience applying for the DECLIN. And one thing I've taken from it is we can add to some of that extra pressure. And if you've got any questions, I'll be really honest about my experiences. And hopefully it can help lots of the other wonderful people thinking about applying next year with their journey. Thank you that's really really helpful and I want to quickly highlight some of the reasons why I was so keen to talk to you if that's okay. We may not have a chance to cover them all because i've got to go and pick my kids up from school in a bit um but you know just so that we can really think about
播客上和我聊聊？谢天谢地，你答应了。是的，申请临床心理学博士课程（DClinPsy）确实是一次充满挑战的经历。我从中体会到的一点是，我们有时会给自己增加额外的压力。如果你有任何问题，我会非常坦诚地分享我的经历。希望这能帮助到许多明年打算申请的优秀人士，让他们在旅程中少走弯路。谢谢，这真的非常有帮助。如果可以的话，我想快速强调一下我为什么这么想和你谈谈。我们可能没机会涵盖所有内容，因为我一会儿得去学校接孩子，但为了让我们能深入思考
some of the issues that you've been um you know that we've been discussing is that you are um age 40 currently is that right yeah yeah i don't act it but technically the birth certificate does say 40 now, yes. You are a parent as well? Yes, I've got a lovely six-and-a-half-year-old, lovely daughter who's an absolute character. Yeah, she's a really big, big driver for me, yes. Amazing, amazing. Best job ever.
我们讨论的一些问题，我想提一下你目前40岁，对吗？是的，虽然我表现得不像，但出生证明上确实写着40岁了。你也是一位家长，对吧？是的，我有一个可爱的六岁半女儿，她性格非常鲜明。是的，她是我前进的巨大动力。太棒了，太棒了。这是世界上最好的工作。
Things we worry about the most but um yeah you get a lot back um you also have diabetes type 1 diabetes yes so me and my wife got married 2015 looking forward to sort of a first year marriage um felt really ill beginning of the year. I actually did an article for the London Economic about Blue Monday because I was feeling really down in January. I was thinking about different reasons that could be. The dip from the wedding, not really having anything, you know, like that to think about that year. Turns out a big reason for feeling quite down
这是我们最担心的事情，但你也会得到很多回报。你还患有1型糖尿病，对吧？是的，我和妻子2015年结婚，本期待着第一年的婚姻生活，但年初时我感觉非常不舒服。我实际上为《伦敦经济报》写过一篇关于“蓝色星期一”的文章，因为我在一月份感到非常沮丧。我当时在想各种可能的原因，比如婚礼后的失落感，或者那一年没什么值得期待的事情。结果发现，感到沮丧的一个重要原因
was I was becoming really ill with type 1 diabetes hadn't realized it yet and it was only when I started to crave water and sugar like a vampire and the pants were starting to sort of get really loose around the waist I thought I need to get to the doctors here actually so uh that was a big a big uh shock and a big fork in the road so to speak but one one I think's been quite helpful actually in a way for the declin process and you know where I am today absolutely we can learn a lot along the way um and your alarm is going off are you gonna be that is my diabetes alarm but i've taken on some sugar my sugars will be covered and sadly treating the hypo is not like poppy with the spinach it does take a little bit of time for
是我患上了1型糖尿病，当时还没意识到。直到我开始像吸血鬼一样渴望水和糖，裤子也开始变得松垮，我才意识到必须去看医生。那是一个巨大的冲击，也是人生中的一个重大转折点。但从某种程度上说，这对DClinPsy的申请过程以及我今天的状态其实很有帮助。绝对的，我们可以在过程中学到很多。你的闹钟响了，那是你的糖尿病闹钟吗？是的，但我已经补充了糖分，血糖会恢复的。遗憾的是，治疗低血糖不像大力水手吃菠菜那样立刻见效，确实需要一点时间
to kick in but i assure you i'll be okay. Okay and this is perhaps an interesting dynamic that might crop up in therapy from time to time as well how does how does that affect things? Sometimes in a very helpful way if you're thinking about engagement with a person I used to work in diabetes prevention again trying to learn from difficulties and my current job I work in bariatric psychology. So it's people living with obesity and it happens more often than you'd maybe hope it happens, but my alarm won't go off during the session. And I've got a treat or hypos, I'm sort of stood during the session
才能起作用，但我保证我会没事的。好的，这或许是治疗中偶尔会出现的一个有趣的动态，这会如何影响治疗呢？有时会以非常有帮助的方式呈现。如果你在思考如何与人互动，我过去曾在糖尿病预防领域工作，再次尝试从困难中学习。我现在的工作是减肥心理学，也就是为肥胖人群提供服务。这种情况发生的频率可能比你预想的要高，但我的闹钟不会在咨询期间响。我必须处理低血糖，我会在咨询期间站着
about thinking about food, regular eating and I'm eating sugary snacks. And this is medicinal, this is medicinal, but I think it can help with engagement and that idea about the person you're talking to is a real person with a real range of experiences. I try to use this as helpfully as I can. And when I was diagnosed, I was lying in the hospital bed thinking, you know, I applied some motivational interviewing sort of techniques thinking, I'm going to have to dance with this and not wrestle. And that was really helpful for coming to terms with accepting and understanding. So even when I got out of hospital the next day, luckily I had that psychology within me to utilise, but I was already on a path of trying to manage it
思考食物、规律饮食，并吃些含糖零食。这虽然是药物，但我认为这有助于建立互动，传达出“你面对的人是一个有着真实经历的真实个体”这一理念。我尽量以最有帮助的方式利用这一点。我刚被诊断时，躺在医院病床上，运用了一些动机访谈的技巧，心想：我必须与它共舞，而不是与之搏斗。这对于接受和理解病情非常有帮助。所以第二天出院时，幸运的是我内心已经具备了心理学知识，我已经走在尝试管理它
and get along with it. Obviously you have ups and downs with it, but it got to the point where when I was doing the Declan application, I didn't want to tick the box for disability confident. And my wife told us I was being stupid. And I took it to supervision. And without telling me I was being stupid, I think my supervisor was wondering similar. And I took it to Facebook. And you even might have commented on the Facebook page about it. But a lot of people didn't. Everybody unanimously said, tick that box, basically. So I listened to everybody and thought, hmm, what's going on there?
并与之共处的道路上了。当然，过程中会有起伏，但到了申请DClinPsy的时候，我不想勾选“残疾自信”（Disability Confident）那个选项。我妻子说我太傻了。我把它带到了督导会上。督导虽然没说我傻，但我认为她也有类似的想法。我把它发到了Facebook上，你甚至可能在页面上评论过。但很多人没有。大家一致认为，基本上必须勾选那个选项。所以我听取了大家的意见，心想，嗯，这是怎么回事？
Am I being too positive and am I ignoring my own role in managing diabetes that has helped my health, but I have to help it to help my health? So I've got a helpful relationship with it I would say on the whole the thing is it's a major major life change it's a major impact and I've only really learned that from my hairdresser has diabetes and has it since she was a child but I've only really learned it as I've watched her become pregnant and have babies and actually it's a whole different not it's not a species but a whole different way of trying to manage your own health which is different than everybody else's health who isn't diabetic and actually it's really empowered her
我是不是太乐观了，忽略了自己在管理糖尿病方面的作用？虽然这有助于我的健康，但我必须辅助它来促进健康。总的来说，我认为我和它之间有一种有益的关系。这是一次重大的人生改变，影响深远。我真正意识到这一点是因为我的理发师也患有糖尿病，她从小就患病。我看着她怀孕生子，才真正明白这与非糖尿病患者管理健康的方式完全不同。这实际上赋予了她力量，
to think about the benefit of really informed practitioners who are either themselves diabetic or have very, very relevant personal experience to carve out specialist roles, you know, and it might well be that there's psychologists, I think there are psychologists working in diabetes services, but there's, you know, that within healthcare, there is kind of diabetic informed practitioners to be able to work with that condition because it changes everything you know before I got to know her well I thought diabetes was about sugar um and it just isn't is it you know it's so complicated it's about everything it's about everything and it's about you know I think the monitors have have helped things a lot but it still affects every area of somebody's life yeah and I think from a psychology point of view and it's a
去思考那些真正了解情况的从业者的价值，他们要么自己是糖尿病患者，要么有非常相关的个人经历，从而开辟出专业角色。我认为医疗保健领域确实有心理学家在糖尿病服务部门工作，但需要更多“糖尿病知情”的从业者来处理这种状况，因为它改变了一切。在深入了解她之前，我以为糖尿病只是关于糖的问题，但事实并非如此，它非常复杂，涉及方方面面。虽然监测仪改善了很多情况，但它仍然影响着一个人生活的方方面面。是的，从心理学角度来看，这是
it's a core a core counseling skill and it's a fundamental but it's that ability for the health professional to really try to hear where somebody is and to be next to them because it's very easy and I know I've done it in the past and I'm really aware of that sort of roadblock within me but to make assumptions make conclusions you know it seems logical that somebody would want to do something for health but how often do people just listen to you should do this and go off and do it? People have different levels of activation, motivation, different priorities, different needs. I think it's really important to sort of recognize where where people are. Diabetes is a tricky thing because you are managing it every minute of every day. It's one of those unique conditions where once a person leaves a room,
一项核心咨询技能，也是根本所在，即医疗专业人员真正尝试倾听对方的处境并陪伴在他们身边的能力。因为这很容易做到——我知道我过去也做过，我非常清楚自己身上那种障碍——即做出假设和结论。似乎逻辑上一个人应该为了健康而做某事，但人们听了“你应该这样做”就真的去做了吗？人们有不同程度的激活水平、动机、优先事项和需求。我认为识别人们所处的阶段非常重要。糖尿病是一件棘手的事情，因为你每时每刻都在管理它。这是那种独特的疾病之一，一旦离开诊室，
they have a huge amount of responsibility potentially where the disease sort of goes. And I think people need to be respected with the challenge of that. And the more the psychologist or the nurse or whoever it is in the care team can meet the person where they are, the greater that person's got a chance of having a really helpful relationship with the health team, with managing a daily condition, that's, you know, for the rest of the life. I was lucky I had the psychology within me to call upon some of those
他们就承担着巨大的责任，决定疾病的发展方向。我认为人们面对这种挑战时需要得到尊重。心理学家、护士或护理团队中的任何人越能与患者站在同一立场，患者与医疗团队建立良好关系、管理终身疾病的机会就越大。我很幸运，我内心具备心理学知识来调用其中一些
skills um but some people don't have those skills and the support around us it's better than what it used to be but it's tricky and it's challenging but i think with that adversity of that condition um plus some of my daughter's adversity i think I think it's trying to sort of reflect and notice how it impacts on you in a positive way, but also possibly, I'm a big fan of Leonard Cohen, and one of his lines is, there's a crack in everything, and that's how the light gets in, and I really keep that in my mind, you you know so even in those sort of dark moments is there potentially even if it's in the future or even small some form of crack of hope an opportunity where eventually if you can just get through the day just get through the day and just get through the day eventually that might grow into something
技能。但有些人没有这些技能，我们周围的支持比过去好了一些，但仍然很棘手。我认为，面对这种疾病的逆境，加上我女儿所经历的逆境，关键在于尝试反思并注意到它如何以积极的方式影响你。我也非常喜欢莱昂纳德·科恩，他的一句歌词是：“万物皆有裂痕，那是光照进来的地方。”我一直把这句话记在心里。所以即使在那些黑暗时刻，是否也可能存在——即使是在未来，或者只是微小的——某种希望的裂缝？只要你能熬过这一天，熬过这一天，最终它可能会成长为某种东西。
hence why I've worked in diabetes prevention and did really well delivering those sessions to patients hence why I think I've ended up at this time in my life being able to get on the declin I've probably answered a second question you've not even asked for haven't i sorry it's all right like honestly there's so many areas of of real that's going to sound really morbid but interest like you've you know you you've alluded to another difficulty there um that your daughter has got health conditions as well yeah yeah so my daughter was born with a just through she had she had bad luck, if you think about genetic conditions, there's a lot of luck in people being healthy, isn't there? As well as what people do when they're older, you need luck. A bit like running a car, things can happen. But yeah, she was born with a complex condition, a number of different issues, problems,
这就是为什么我从事糖尿病预防工作，并且在向患者传达这些课程时做得很好。这就是为什么我觉得在人生的这个阶段，我能够进入DClinPsy。我可能回答了你还没问出的第二个问题，对吧？抱歉。没关系，说实话，有很多领域真的——这听起来可能很病态——很有趣。你提到了另一个困难，你女儿也有健康状况，对吧？是的，我女儿出生时，如果考虑到遗传疾病，这纯粹是运气不好。人们是否健康，很大程度上取决于运气，不仅仅是他们年长后做了什么，你需要运气。就像开车一样，事情随时可能发生。但她出生时就患有一种复杂的疾病，伴随许多不同的问题，
dozens of operations. She had her last one two years today. I was telling you about it earlier, which was essentially a gastric bypass. So on a four-year-old, in my interview for bariatric psychology, coming up to nearly two years ago, said that my daughter had a gastric bypass but i didn't tell them the context why it was only when i came off the phone i went how on earth did that land how did his daughter have a gastric bypass this is for people living with obesity so i sent an email when i got off at the job going can i just explain what i meant by that
做了几十次手术。两年前的今天她做了最后一次手术。我之前跟你提过，本质上是一个胃旁路手术。对于一个四岁的孩子来说，在两年前我申请减肥心理学职位的面试中，我说我女儿做了胃旁路手术，但我没有说明背景原因。挂断电话后，我心想：这听起来多离谱啊，他女儿怎么会做胃旁路手术？这是针对肥胖人群的。所以我拿到工作后发了一封邮件，说：我能解释一下我那句话的意思吗？
what i was trying to say was i've got some experience from a personal point of view but about during the interview it didn't i didn't actually give the context but i think you know i'm not gonna lie it was absolutely brutal particularly the first year and for me again using psychology at that point there's no manual that says how to get through those times and I sort of remember thinking I'll get through each day and if it works for one day I'll try it the next day and if it doesn't I'll try something else and I know people talk about being mindful being in the moment there's times where you know what you want to be away from that actually and distraction could be the key thing you need to be a bit more present the next day and I think it's one of those things where if you get through the day that's a massive success but people did say to us things would get better at around four or five years. I mean, it took a gastric bypass for my daughter to start improving.
我想说的是，我从个人角度有一些经验。但在面试中，我实际上没有给出背景。但我认为，我不撒谎，那段经历绝对是残酷的，尤其是第一年。对我来说，再次运用心理学，当时没有任何手册说明如何度过那些时光。我记得当时想：我只要熬过每一天，如果这一天有效，我就尝试下一天；如果不行，我就尝试别的方法。我知道人们谈论正念、活在当下，但有时你确实想远离那一刻，分心可能是你需要的关键。你需要第二天更专注一点。我认为如果能熬过这一天，那就是巨大的成功。但人们确实告诉我们，四五岁左右情况会好转。我的意思是，直到我女儿做了胃旁路手术，情况才开始改善。
But you know what? It sort of did around the age of five. And through going to work and that adversity, I mean, there was times where I was like living in the hospital, like literally with my work stuff, clothes, leaving the ward, bye, I'm off to work, say bye to the nurses, coming back afterwards. And I look back now and I think, how and why did I do that? But in terms of training, in terms of being resilient, for me personally,
但你知道吗？在五岁左右，情况确实好转了。通过工作和面对那些逆境——我的意思是，有时我感觉就像住在医院里，带着工作用品、衣服，离开病房说“再见，我去上班了”，跟护士道别，结束后又回来。我现在回想起来，心想：我当时是怎么做到的，为什么要那样做？但在培训方面，在培养韧性方面，对我个人而言，
it was really helpful because it was always going to be a long haul this. It wasn't going to be a quick fix or anything like that. But it gave me a platform to grow in my career. So from the diabetes prevention work I did, I ended up working in a role where I was a team leader. I was training social workers on MI and CBT. I was a team leader I was training social workers on MI and CBT I was doing my casework with patients and had the biggest caseload and working with the most amount of GPs so in a in a way I sort of felt quite fit you know at work and um I'd written myself off again Again, I was telling you about my roadblock of ageism. I was writing myself off in terms of declin and felt the ship had sailed. I'd squandered my best chance of getting on in my 20s by just enjoying my 20s too much.
这非常有帮助，因为这注定是一场持久战，不是什么快速修复的方法。但这为我的职业发展提供了一个平台。通过我所做的糖尿病预防工作，我最终担任了团队负责人的角色。我培训社会工作者学习动机访谈（MI）和认知行为疗法（CBT）。我当时在做病例工作，拥有最大的病例量，与最多的全科医生合作。所以从某种程度上说，我在工作中感觉非常胜任。而且，我又一次写下了自己——我之前跟你提过我的年龄歧视障碍。我在DClinPsy申请方面否定了自己，觉得机会已经错过了。我在20多岁时因为玩得太疯，浪费了最好的申请机会。
Somebody said to me, Mark, look at what you're doing at work every single week. I just stood back and thought, this is like working like a clinical psychologist. So I thought, I'm going to have another go. I'm going to apply. And, you know, I'm really, really grateful I did. Yeah, absolutely. And I think all of your future clients will be really grateful as well. And your cohort, they're going to be delighted to get to be part of your life and to benefit from your rich experience um and there's
有人对我说：“Mark，看看你每周在工作中做的事情。”我退后一步想，这就像临床心理学家的工作。所以我决定再试一次，我要申请。而且，我真的非常非常感激我这么做了。是的，绝对的。我相信你未来的所有客户也会非常感激。你的同伴们也会很高兴能成为你生活的一部分，并从你丰富的经验中受益。而且还有
further adversity to come in case everybody thinks oh that's surely enough that's enough um i'm yeah really sad to say that both of your both of your parents died when you were a child. Yeah, yeah. I hope people have tissues. I don't know. But no, I don't cry about it. And, you know, I've done my crying many, many years ago. It's something that has been so long ago now that it does have an impact,
更多的逆境要来，以防大家觉得“这肯定够了，这已经够多了”。我非常难过地说，你的父母在你小时候都去世了。是的，是的。我希望大家准备好纸巾。我不知道。但我不为此哭泣。而且，我很多年前就已经哭过了。那是很久以前的事情了，它确实有影响，
but not like an acute uh problem these days and most of my life i've lived without my parents so it is something that i've gradually adjusted to i found it hard when i was a child obviously um in different ways once you know my mom died removed school i was very quiet uh all of a sudden from being really you know chatty in this new you know in a new school I was very quiet and I did my work and I was doing my work within a few minutes and I used work to distract myself from being in that environment after my mama died but I sort of realized I was fairly intelligent as well. So that became an unhelpful coping strategy in a way because I was also competitive.
但现在已经不是一个急性问题了。我生命中大部分时间都是在没有父母的情况下度过的，所以我已经逐渐适应了。小时候我当然觉得很难。我妈妈去世后，我转学了，突然变得非常安静，从以前在新学校里非常健谈的状态变得很沉默。我很快就完成了作业，我利用工作来分散注意力，让自己不去想妈妈去世后的环境。但我意识到自己也相当聪明。所以从某种程度上说，这成了一种无益的应对策略，因为我也很好胜。
So I wanted to be the quickest and the best at everything. And I still have that in me, but it's quieted down a little bit that competitive streak. But I went to high school, a 2,000-pupil school, just after my dad died. And that was really challenging because I'd moved back to Newcastle from the countryside, Northumberland, where my nana lived. And all of a sudden, I'm in the town again. And the people are slightly different compared to you know northumberland you know a lot more you know a lot more direct a lot more um so confident and you know brash i guess
所以我想要成为最快、最好的人。我内心依然有这种特质，但那种好胜心已经平息了一些。但我父亲去世后，我去了高中，那是一所拥有2000名学生的学校。这真的非常具有挑战性，因为我从我奶奶居住的诺森伯兰郡乡村搬回了纽卡斯尔。突然间，我又回到了城镇。人们与诺森伯兰郡的人略有不同，他们更直接，更自信，而且我想说，更粗鲁。
at least on the surface and going to a 2000il school after your dad had died, it was really, really difficult, really tough. And I remember as an unhelpful behavioural strategy fighting a lot, you know, because I was so frightened that I thought if I lash out almost, like, it's going to keep me safe. But it didn't. It just got me more attention. So it was a really maladaptive thing uh with hindsight um but again it was trying to find like an identity for me
至少在表面上是这样。在父亲去世后进入一所2000人的学校，真的非常非常困难。我记得作为一种无益的行为策略，我经常打架，因为我太害怕了，心想如果我反击，这会让我感到安全。但并没有。这只会让我受到更多关注。所以事后看来，这是一种非常适应不良的行为，但再次强调，这只是在尝试寻找一种身份认同。
and i think that's probably why up until i became a 30 year old person living with my now wife i didn't have that identity i didn't have that stability in my life i probably didn't get it till me me and my wife moved in when i was 30 which at which point your pancreas decided to yeah exactly just just to just to give us another curveball but uh yeah i could be a charver i could be a swat i could be a sporty person i could be a class clown i was just so dysregulated and um although i did well at a levels well sorry i didn't do well at a levels i actually failed my psychology a level because i had further adversity around that time but the university took me on i got a 2.1 i did a master's i struggled with that but i was
我想这可能就是为什么直到我30岁与现在的妻子生活在一起之前，我都没有那种身份认同，生活中也没有那种稳定性。我可能直到30岁我们搬到一起住时才获得，而就在那时，你的胰腺决定——是的，完全正确，只是为了给我们制造另一个难题。但我当时可能是一个混混，可能是一个书呆子，可能是一个爱运动的人，也可能是班里的开心果。我当时太失调了。虽然我在A-Level考试中表现不错——抱歉，我A-Level考试没考好，因为那时我经历了更多的逆境，我心理学A-Level挂科了。但大学录取了我，我拿到了2.1学位，读了硕士，虽然过程很挣扎，但我
so dysregulated through my 20s and you know if i did have a tip for people you know based on my own experience and I imagine this might be a minority thing but it's just check in on where your head and emotion is at that point because although in some ways I felt I was ready for Declan and good enough with hindsight my emotional intelligence my stability I just wasn't anywhere near it um hence why i'm a little bit old i get onto declan i think we get there when we're ready you know absolutely i believe that um but with my psychology head on i'm thinking gosh with the greatest deal of respect you could be one of my clients you know um absolutely there's there's enough experiences here that many other people not paying yet no it's fine you know many people
在20多岁时非常失调。如果我能给人们一个基于我个人经验的建议——我想这可能只是少数情况——那就是检查一下你当时的心理和情绪状态。因为虽然在某些方面我觉得自己已经为DClinPsy做好了准备，也足够优秀，但事后看来，我的情商和稳定性还远远不够。这就是为什么我年纪稍大才进入DClinPsy。我认为我们准备好了自然就会到达那里。绝对的，我相信这一点。但以我的心理学视角来看，我心想：天哪，带着最大的敬意，你完全可以成为我的客户。绝对的，这里有足够的经历，许多其他人
would have have really struggled with this along the way and would have faltered and it would be understandable given these nature of cumulative things that life got tricky but also with my psychologist head on I think gosh you must have some really you don't need to disclose them but you must have some really strong protective factors obviously your intelligence is one of them but there's you know we're always looking at well why isn't this a problem why isn't this as well as why is this why now but you know protective factors can do a great deal yeah i've got a i guess i've got a competitive pride like i mentioned earlier and um like a determination to i guess when you've had quite a lot of adversity one thing that may happen
在这一路上会非常挣扎，会动摇，考虑到这些累积的事情，生活变得棘手是可以理解的。但以我的心理学家视角，我心想：天哪，你一定有一些非常——你不需要透露它们——但你一定有一些非常强大的保护因素。显然你的智力是其中之一，但我们总是会看：为什么这不是一个问题？为什么是现在？但保护因素确实能起到很大作用。是的，我想我有一种好胜的自尊心，就像我之前提到的，还有一种决心。我想当你经历了很多逆境，有一件事可能会发生，
eventually is you become familiar with it and you become aware that some of that adversity might sort of gradually chip away to some degree um through time but also that there might be things that we can do to to sort of heal from that adversity so it might still be there and it might still be with you but it could be further away it might not come out as often potentially or the trigger situations might be a bit more few and far between um but i mean my protective factor now is obviously you know my my family um but one one thing i didn't say about my dad was he was a competitive person and he had the opportunity to go to university to be a doctor like a medical doctor he didn't want to leave Newcastle and I mean in my wedding speech I did I did mention that and I did say I hope to you know follow in his footsteps so even though he
最终你会变得熟悉它，并意识到其中一些逆境可能会随着时间推移逐渐消磨掉。但同时，我们也可能做些事情来从那种逆境中治愈。所以它可能依然存在，可能依然伴随着你，但它可能会离你更远，可能不会那么频繁地出现，或者触发情境可能会少一些。但我的保护因素现在显然是我的家人。但我有一件事没说，关于我父亲，他是一个好胜的人，他曾有机会去大学成为一名医生，一名医学博士。但他不想离开纽卡斯尔。在我的婚礼致辞中，我提到了这一点，我说我希望追随他的脚步。所以即使他
passed away coming up 30 years it's still a driver in me um but it's not just to make him proud i said this on father's day when i was at the crematorium but it's it's also to like in a jokingly way but get one up on him so he was competitive could have been a doctor and uh i'd be i'd be lying if i said like like you know but you know deep down he's going to be proud deep down he will be proud that I've done it but it is a little bit of competition getting one up on him because he's such a
去世快30年了，这依然是我内心的驱动力。但这不仅仅是为了让他骄傲。我在父亲节去火葬场时说过，这也有点开玩笑的成分，就是想胜过他。他很好胜，本可以成为一名医生。如果我说我不想胜过他，那我就是在撒谎。但你知道，内心深处，他会为我感到骄傲。他会为我做到这一点而感到骄傲。但这确实有一点竞争的意味，想胜过他，因为他是一个如此
talented man he really was but it has spurred me on and I know we've all got different reasons for wanting to get on the decline most of mine are obviously about psychology and what I want to do to, you know, assist people in difficulties and in distress. But I think being aware of your personal drivers is really important.
有才华的人，他确实是。但这激励了我。我知道我们每个人想进入DClinPsy的原因各不相同。我大部分的原因显然是关于心理学，以及我想做些什么来帮助处于困境和痛苦中的人们。但我认为意识到你个人的驱动力非常重要。
As one of your books, you know, reports, we've all got them. And again, Marianne, I know in your book, you talk about being in a lecture theater hearing about clinical psychology and somebody saying basically oh don't even bother essentially yep bingo i remember the same conversation sit you know same lecturer saying something very similar and me going i'll show you you know it's that competitiveness I guess possibly telling me not to do something I'll show you I'll get there then I'll like tell everyone about how you told me not to do it but I think you also um touch really nicely on on a grief issue there which is how
正如你的一本书中所述，我们都有这些驱动力。而且，Marianne，我知道在你的书中，你谈到在阶梯教室里听到关于临床心理学的讲座，有人基本上说“哦，别费心了”。是的，宾果！我记得同样的对话，同一个讲师说了非常类似的话，而我心想：我会证明给你看。这就是那种好胜心，可能有人告诉我不要做某事，我会证明给你看。我会到达那里，然后我会告诉所有人你是怎么告诉我不要做的。但我认为你也非常巧妙地触及了一个悲伤的问题，那就是
we can actually keep the presence of someone we loved with us in the present and have it be about continuing that relationship that never got a chance to reach its natural conclusion in longer life. And it's something I do with my dad as well. You know, I think about what would he say about that? What would he do about that? Or, you know, would I tease him about that? Yes, I would and it's really nice that you can still have that playful element even though your dad's not here yeah yeah yeah I agree it's something nobody ever taught me to do um
我们实际上如何将我们所爱之人的存在保留在当下，并让它成为延续那段没有机会在更长生命中达到自然结论的关系。这也是我对我父亲所做的事情。你知道，我会想：他会对这个说什么？他会怎么做？或者，我会拿这个逗他吗？是的，我会的。即使你父亲不在了，还能有那种俏皮的元素，这真的很好。是的，是的，我同意。这是从来没有人教过我做的事情。
and if that's a helpful strategy that you share with some of your clients going through grief that's something that when I was like 11 or 12 um I I just sort of did and it helped me with sort of getting through different periods I used to um if I was struggling with motivation or something I used to sort of say like do it for me dad you'll do it for dad and that was something I would like sort of call upon to to spur me on as a coping strategy um and yeah it is something that's sort of call upon to spur me on as a coping strategy. And yeah, it is something that's sort of still in me, but it doesn't come out of these days like I needed it to when I was a teenager. I think probably in my 20s, actually, I forgot about that and didn't maybe call upon it enough.
如果这是一种你与一些经历悲伤的客户分享的有益策略，那是我在11或12岁时就自然而然做的事情，它帮助我度过了不同的时期。如果我在动力方面遇到困难，我会说：“为了我爸爸做，为了爸爸做。”那是我会调用来激励自己的一种应对策略。是的，这确实是我仍然保留的东西，但现在不像我十几岁时那样需要它了。我想可能在20多岁时，我忘记了这一点，可能没有足够多地调用它。
Hence why I had such a good time at university and not enough uh studying and you know um yeah lack of emotional intelligence let's say but um you're right you get there when you're ready don't you and there's a lot of readiness we do all do slightly sillier things you know before we've got our full frontal lobes as well so you might be being slightly harsh on yourself, you know. We're supposed to be like playful adolescent monkeys, you know, going off to go and wrestle and have fun with our colleagues and friends. And, you know, coming into scrapes and then coming back into the fold in the evening and it's maybe you know I hope that you had a fold that felt safe and loving but your fold would have looked a little bit different than than the average 2.4 family would have done yeah yeah no yeah that's definitely
这就是为什么我在大学里玩得那么开心，而学习不够。你知道，缺乏情商，我们可以这么说。但你是对的，当你准备好了，你就会到达那里，对吧？我们确实在额叶完全发育之前做过一些稍微愚蠢的事情，所以你可能对自己有点苛刻。我们本应该是那种爱玩耍的青春期猴子，去和同事朋友摔跤、玩耍。经历一些挫折，然后在晚上回到安全的港湾。我希望你有一个感到安全和充满爱的港湾，但你的港湾可能看起来与普通的2.4口之家有点不同。是的，是的，那绝对是
that's definitely the case I mean I am aware like during times, I still got A2 on, and I still managed to do a master's. I used my dad's inheritance to self-fund the master's. I expected to do it within a year. I didn't want to go to work when I finished my degree. Just do a few essays, do an assignment, dead easy. First paper back, this is a poor piece of work 35 you know oh big shock big shock this is going to be a lot lot bigger a lot more challenging but that just shows where my head was i was either too high or too low and um that's what i mean about checking in with sort of head
事实。我的意思是，我意识到在那些时期，我仍然通过了A2考试，并且仍然设法完成了硕士学位。我用父亲的遗产自费完成了硕士学位。我本以为一年内就能完成。我不想在完成学位后去工作。只要写几篇论文，做一个作业，太容易了。第一篇论文回来，这是一篇糟糕的作品，35分。哦，巨大的冲击，巨大的冲击。这将会大得多，更具挑战性。但这只是显示了我当时的心态，我要么太高，要么太低。这就是我所说的关于检查
space and readiness and and just just sort of making sure that you know the situation around you feels stable enough you know like we might do with patients on the bariatric pathway is this the right time is this going to help you more than it's potentially going to hinder and um yeah yeah just just i guess know yourself as well as possible because we spend so much time thinking about the course, what the panel might be like, what to put on the form. But I know you talk about, you know, sort of self-compassion. You talk about, you know, kindness and patience quite often, but it's a neglected area potentially to somebody's preparation for this career.
心理空间和准备状态，并确保你周围的情况感觉足够稳定。就像我们在减肥路径上对待患者那样：这是正确的时机吗？这会比潜在的阻碍更有帮助吗？尽可能了解自己，因为我们花太多时间思考课程、面试小组会是什么样、表格上填什么。但我知道你经常谈论自我同情、善良和耐心，但这可能是职业准备中被忽视的一个领域。
Absolutely, absolutely. You've mentioned motivational interviewing quite a few times and I know that there might be some people listening to this who are thinking, oh, I should know what that is or maybe even earlier in their career and think I've not heard of that could you save people a google and explore explain briefly what motivational interviewing is and why it's so good yeah so motivational interviewing is a style of having a conversation with a person and it's not about, I think about it like this. So if you're trying to help your child into the water,
绝对的，绝对的。你提到了好几次动机访谈，我知道可能有一些听众在想：哦，我应该知道那是什么，或者可能在职业生涯早期，心想：我没听说过那个。你能省去大家谷歌搜索的时间，简要解释一下什么是动机访谈，以及为什么它这么好吗？好的，动机访谈是一种与人交谈的风格。它不是关于——我是这样想的。如果你试图帮助你的孩子下水，
I'm totally nicking off Steve, roll Nicky up by the way, but you know, instead of like trying to push them in or to pull them in to change, to doing something, you're next to the person and you're using some uh conversational skills that essentially are from sort of Rogers and a person-centered way of working with someone um to really try to ask open questions find out what matters to them what's really important to them um you know so if you're thinking about blood sugar it might not be important for them at that moment to manage your blood sugar it might be important
我完全是借用Steve Rollnick的说法，顺便提一下，但你知道，与其试图把他们推下去或拉下去来改变，让他们做某事，你是在那个人身边，并使用一些本质上来自罗杰斯（Rogers）和以人为本的工作方式的对话技巧，真正尝试提出开放式问题，找出对他们来说什么重要，什么对他们来说真正重要。所以如果你在考虑血糖，对他们来说，在那一刻管理血糖可能并不重要，可能重要的是
to do something else but if you can have that conversation about what something else looks like you might be able to then trickle down no pun intended to something that could help them with thinking about their diabetes differently seeing how those two things fit together. So it's really a style of conversation I alluded to earlier that looks more like a dance with the patient. So I know when I'm talking to people, if it feels like it's getting tense, if it feels like it's getting difficult, and the answers are becoming short, I'll just sort of check in on that and just sort of
做别的事情。但如果你能就别的事情是什么进行对话，你也许就能——没有双关的意思——顺水推舟，做一些能帮助他们以不同方式思考糖尿病的事情，看看这两者是如何结合在一起的。所以这确实是一种对话风格，我之前提到过，看起来更像是与患者共舞。我知道当我和人们交谈时，如果感觉气氛变得紧张，如果感觉变得困难，回答变得简短，我会检查一下，然后
go back to how it's going but it's it's something you could use with other approaches so you can use it with like act you can use it with cft you can use it with cbt it's not something you you do on its own in my opinion it complements some of the other work um but finding out what really matters to the person what really matters to the person yeah and then you can use that to be the difference that makes a difference yeah yeah definitely there's lots of resources out there about motivational interviewing lovely thank you for filling in that gap because that's not something we've spoken about in the podcast so far so what are you hoping to gain from training
回到进展情况。但这是你可以与其他方法结合使用的东西，所以你可以把它与接纳承诺疗法（ACT）、同情聚焦疗法（CFT）、认知行为疗法（CBT）结合使用。在我看来，它不是你可以单独使用的东西，它补充了其他工作。但找出对那个人真正重要的事情，对那个人真正重要的事情，是的，然后你可以利用这一点成为带来改变的差异。是的，是的，绝对的。关于动机访谈有很多资源。太好了，谢谢你填补了这个空白，因为这是我们播客中目前还没谈到的话题。那么你希望从培训中获得什么？
at risk of making you answer your declan cyphum all over again what are you hoping to gain from training or what are you looking forward to about these next three years so personally it it's felt like a recovery for me given the potential i had and the decisions I might have made that took me away from that and then some of the adversity that you know landed into our lives so it feels like you know it's a symbol of recovery from that and I'm I couldn't have done that without psychology because psychology over the last few years has helped me with that growth and that adversity and managing some of those difficulties. So for me, I'm looking forward to learning more about psychology, becoming a far more helpful, well-rounded practitioner. And the university I'm going to really encourages you to become the practitioner you want to become, which is
冒着让你再次回答DClinPsy申请问题的风险，你希望从培训中获得什么，或者你对未来三年有什么期待？就个人而言，考虑到我拥有的潜力以及我可能做出的让我远离潜力的决定，然后是一些降临到我们生活中的逆境，这感觉像是一种恢复。所以它感觉像是那种恢复的象征。如果没有心理学，我不可能做到这一点，因为过去几年的心理学帮助我实现了那种成长，面对了逆境，并管理了一些困难。所以对我来说，我期待学习更多心理学知识，成为一名更有帮助、更全面的从业者。而且我即将去的大学非常鼓励你成为你想成为的从业者，这就是
wonderful for me because I feel quite versatile and curious about different approaches. But I also hope that when it comes to retirement, how old will I be? 65, 70, who knows? I can look back on, you know, the next 30 years and sort of feel like I've made a contribution to psychology. So I don't just mean with the services I work into and the patients I meet. I'm really passionate. And I know this could be a cliche, but the systems, you know, so to use Dr. Kamara Jones's analogy of the dust factory producing loads of dust giving people masks to wear treating them for the condition you know the chest problems but
对我来说这很棒，因为我觉得自己适应力很强，对不同的方法充满好奇。但我也希望，当退休的时候，我会多大年纪呢？65岁，70岁，谁知道呢？我可以回顾过去，你知道，接下来的30年，感觉自己为心理学做出了贡献。我指的不仅仅是我所从事的服务和我遇到的病人。我真的很有热情。我知道这可能是一句陈词滥调，但那些系统，你知道，就像卡马拉·琼斯博士（Dr. Kamara Jones）关于“灰尘工厂”的比喻：工厂产生大量灰尘，给人们戴上口罩，治疗他们的病症，你知道，胸部问题，但是
actually tackling the factory itself that's sort of where I hope my work takes me doing some work with people who are struggling with some of the difficulties, but doing something that really informs the societal, cultural community change. And if I train other people along the way, or supervise people along the way, who look back and say Mark's been a helpful influence, I'll take that at 70, if I get there.
实际上是去解决工厂本身的问题。这就是我希望我的工作能带我去的方向：做一些与那些正在经历困难的人们一起工作的事情，但也要做一些真正能促进社会、文化和社区变革的事情。如果我在这个过程中培训了其他人，或者指导了其他人，他们回头看时说“马克是一个有益的影响”，如果我能活到70岁，我会接受这一点。
I'll take that. I'll be quite happy with that. But I'm really excited because, you know, 20 years ago when me and you were in those lecture theatres hearing about clinical psychology and that sort of spark happened 20 years later, you know, four decades, 99, I started my A-levels. I'm just going to remember to be grounded, not too high or low, and to appreciate being on that course. There's going to be challenges.
我会接受的。我会为此感到非常高兴。但我真的很兴奋，因为，你知道，20年前我和你在那些阶梯教室里听关于临床心理学的课程，那种火花在20年后，你知道，四十年了，99年，我开始读A-level课程。我只是要记住要脚踏实地，不要太高调或低调，并珍惜能参加那门课程的机会。会有挑战的。
There's going to be bumps. I'm going to ask for help. I'm going to put my hand up. And I'm going to do my best and really relish the opportunity. And I'm looking forward to the cohort itself. They seem really lovely from our social media conversations. I might be one of the older people, who knows, but I'm going to be enthusiastic and fun,
会有坎坷的。我会寻求帮助。我会举手示意。我会尽我所能，真正享受这个机会。我很期待这个群体本身。从我们的社交媒体对话来看，他们看起来真的很可爱。我可能是年纪较大的人之一，谁知道呢，但我会保持热情和乐趣，
and hopefully people will not realise I'm 40 when this starts, unless we're watchers, obviously, because this gives it away. But I think there's so much i don't know i felt like 41 was a bit of a dodgy year for me for a variety of reasons but 40 i was just just loved life like i felt really vibrant my children were a little bit older i felt like i'd come out of the kind of grief dip that i'd been in and you know i just felt I felt really good. I was the healthiest probably I've ever been. Like, yeah, I felt like 40, it felt like a big deal. But actually when I got there, I was so proud to be 40 and, you know,
希望人们不会意识到我开始这个课程时已经40岁了，除非我们是视频观看者，显然，因为这会暴露年龄。但我认为有很多我不知道的事情。我觉得41岁对我来说因为各种原因有点棘手，但40岁时我只是热爱生活，我感觉非常有活力，我的孩子们大了一点，我觉得我已经走出了我一直处于的那种悲伤低谷，你知道，我只是感觉我感觉真的很好。我可能是我有生以来最健康的。是的，我觉得40岁，这感觉是一件大事。但实际上当我到了那个年纪，我为自己40岁感到非常自豪，而且，你知道，
to be the product of my own experiences and all of the people that had shaped me along the way and um as i say that i'm mindful of sometimes people say is there like a limit to the number of um relevant experience roles you can put in on the declensi form having read yours i'm going to say no like yours went on for pages and pages and pages and pages and pages but you know all of those experiences we have with us and we take with our client sessions and with our parenting you know and I felt so proud to be 40 and I'm now 42 having recently turned 42 but to have all those experiences with me and to have that within the room with clients yeah it's trying to say it in a helpful way as a
成为我自己经历的产物，以及所有在这一路上塑造我的人的产物。嗯，当我这么说的时候，我注意到有时人们会问，在申请表上填写的相关经验角色数量是否有限制？读了你的之后，我要说没有，因为你的写了好多页好多页。但你知道，我们拥有的所有这些经历都伴随着我们，我们把它们带入客户会话和育儿中。你知道，我为自己40岁感到非常自豪，我现在42岁，刚满42岁，但拥有所有这些经历，并把它们带入与客户的房间里，是的，这是试图以一种有益的方式将其表述为
strength and and to have that sort of you know brush of compassion to you know paint it in a helpful way but it's interesting you mentioned about experience and I would always go back to I know it says this in the guidance but the quality of experience so one benefit of my career path is I've had a couple of jobs where I'm working with people every single day Monday to Friday and I was able to do that for a period of a couple of years in one job and that for me was so helpful early on in my career so I would be supportive of people thinking about working in supported housing for a reason because just my experience, yeah, it was really helpful to see the wider determinants of health at play.
一种力量，并拥有那种，你知道，同情的触感，你知道，以一种有益的方式来描绘它。但有趣的是你提到了经验，我总是会回到——我知道指导方针里是这么说的——经验的质量。所以我职业道路的一个好处是，我有几份工作是每天，周一到周五，都在与人打交道，我能够在一份工作中连续做了几年，这对我职业生涯早期的帮助非常大。所以我支持人们考虑在支持性住房工作，原因就是我的经历，是的，看到更广泛的健康决定因素在起作用真的很有帮助。
You know, you get to know people and you find out about their sort of life experience and adversities and you're able to sort of start mapping it out. And I didn't know I was formulating at that point, but that's what I was doing is I was taking in people's narratives and stories. But I think it gives you a really rich experience. And it's that lived experience that can really inform as much. I don't want to be too controversial and say more than a textbook or more than a lecture, but in terms of the colourful way of learning, watching somebody and getting to know somebody in front of your eyes
你知道，你开始了解人们，发现他们的生活经历和逆境，你就能开始把它们映射出来。我当时并不知道我在进行案例构思，但那就是我正在做的事情，我正在吸收人们的叙述和故事。但我认为这给了你非常丰富的经验。正是这种生活经验可以真正提供很多信息。我不想太有争议地说比教科书或讲座更多，但就学习的丰富方式而言，观察某人并在你眼前了解某人
and having that honour to be in their lives is just so powerful and it really helped me become the person-centered person that I am you know working next to the person as an equal um and it's I've loved last few years seeing the NHS sort of catch up on that sort of spirit it's a long time coming but it's better late than never I guess um I would definitely echo that I think so I think i said in the clinpsite book i was a home carer for about a year or so i learned so much about dignity and respect and compassion and just being a really good human first as an intervention, you know. I use it every day.
并有幸进入他们的生活是如此强大，它真的帮助我成为了我现在的以人为本的人，你知道，作为平等的一方在人身边工作。嗯，我很高兴过去几年看到英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）赶上了那种精神，虽然来得晚了一些，但总比不来好，我想。嗯，我绝对会附和这一点。我想我在《临床心理学家集体》（ClinPsy Collective）书里说过，我做过大约一年的家庭护理员，我学到了很多关于尊严、尊重和同情的知识，首先作为一个干预措施，做一个真正的好人，你知道。我每天都在使用它。
You don't have to do psychology. You don't have to do psychology necessarily. If you just meet them in a very equal way and you listen and you're just there, that can be powerful. I think for me it's the treating people as important so um at the time I was working with um colleagues who would be very much trying to rush the jobs to get them done as quick as they could so they could get out the door and still claim their full wage and get home um and sometimes I would turn up to what was supposed to be double-handed jobs
你不必非得做心理学。你不必非得做心理学。如果你只是以一种非常平等的方式与他们见面，倾听他们，只是陪伴在那里，那可能就很强大。我认为对我来说，这是把人当作重要的人来对待。所以，嗯，当时我和同事一起工作，他们非常急于赶快完成工作，这样他们就可以出门，仍然领取全额工资并回家。嗯，有时我会去那些本应该是双人合作的工作，
and the client was already in bed because they'd done it themselves and that's like I was to time because if there was extra time if it was just to go in and you know make them a cup of tea and then check the doors locked call really for 15 minutes I would sit and massage their legs with cream because they looked a bit dry and they'd be like oh you sure you don't need to dash off and I was like no I've got I've got another seven minutes we can we can do whatever and sometimes they'd say will you just watch Coronation Street with me and I was like yes of course I will um because that's part of being human and I could almost see them like really puzzled. Why are you wanting to do this?
而客户已经上床睡觉了，因为他们自己完成了。那就像我准时到达，如果还有额外的时间，如果只是进去，你知道，给他们泡杯茶，然后检查门锁好，实际上只需要15分钟，我就会坐下来用润肤霜按摩他们的腿，因为它们看起来有点干。他们会说：“哦，你确定不需要赶快走吗？”我说：“不，我还有七分钟，我们可以做任何事。”有时他们会说：“你会陪我一起看《加冕街》（Coronation Street）吗？”我说：“是的，当然会。”因为那是做人的一部分。我几乎可以看到他们真的很困惑。你为什么要这样做？
But it's because A, you matter to me, but B, I don't want to be in the nature of fraud. You know, if I've said I'm going to be here for 15 minutes, I'm damn well going to be here and I'm going to do your washing up and I'm going to change your bedsheets and I'm not just going to make you that cup of tea because you matter.
但这是因为，第一，你对我来说很重要；第二，我不想欺骗。你知道，如果我说我要在这里待15分钟，我该死地会待在这里，我会帮你洗碗，我会帮你换床单，我不仅仅是给你泡那杯茶，因为你很重要。
And I think that's what we get from relevant experience roles. Yeah, no, definitely, definitely. And you could have chose not to. But for you, your values, your character, you were very self-aware about how I would land, how I would feel. And yeah, you know, you give a damn, essentially. Yeah. That said, I've never lost more sleep than when it was my job to lock people's doors. Then I'd be like, all right, did I?
我认为这就是我们从相关经验角色中得到的。是的，不，绝对是，绝对是。你可以选择不这样做。但对你来说，你的价值观，你的性格，你对自己会产生什么影响，会有什么感觉非常自觉。而且，你知道，你确实在乎，本质上。是的。话虽如此，我从未像负责锁门时那样失眠。那时我会想，好吧，我锁了吗？
Did I put the key back in the key safe? Did I? Did I? Like, it's a lot of responsibility,'t it yeah i can imagine imagine right this is taking an unexpected turn but it all feels so deep and so rich and so i hope what feels useful inspiring and engaging for people um you've given us lots and lots of really great take home nuggets about reducing burnout on the way to, you know, doctorate courses. Have you got any other kind of parting words of wisdom? Yes, I think it's important. And I know you talk about patience and compassion, being authentic, you know, being yourself on the form. We're not looking to catch you out.
我把钥匙放回钥匙箱了吗？我放了吗？我放了吗？这责任很大，不是吗？是的，我可以想象，想象一下。好吧，这发生了意想不到的转折，但这一切感觉如此深刻和丰富，所以我希望这对人们来说是有用、鼓舞人心和引人入胜的。你给了我们很多非常棒的带回家的要点，关于在通往博士课程的路上减少倦怠。你还有其他临别赠言吗？是的，我认为这很重要。我知道你谈论耐心和同情心，要真实，你知道，在表格上做你自己。我们不是要抓住你的把柄。
I couldn't say I do this and do that and do that when I've got a daughter with disabilities where what I do is a lot of extra work and support around her. So I think be authentic on that part of the form. I think regardless of the outcome, and I accept this is really, really challenging, but the fact that you're doing the application form, just take a bit of moment every now and again to recognise that you're doing that form and what that says about you as a person, as a practitioner,
我不能说我做这个、做那个、做那个，当我有一个残疾的女儿，我所做的是围绕她进行大量的额外工作和支持。所以我认为在表格的那部分要真实。我认为无论结果如何，我承认这真的、真的很有挑战性，但你正在填写申请表这一事实，时不时花点时间认识到你正在填写那份表格，以及这说明了你作为一个人、作为一个从业者是什么样的人，
and to really, yeah, just appreciate the enormity of it, I guess. And I think if you are feeling distress and difficulty while you're going through the form, my experience from talking to people is that the process doesn't half add to a lot of that. So it's nothing in you if so many people are feeling that that says something about the system the process itself so i think just you know being really kind take your time with it uh take breaks don't do too much work on it get four people maybe maximum to have a look at people
并真正地，是的，只是欣赏它的巨大意义，我想。我认为如果你在填写表格时感到痛苦和困难，我从与人们交谈中得到的经验是，这个过程确实加剧了其中的很多痛苦。所以如果这么多人都有这种感觉，那不是你的问题，这说明了系统和过程本身。所以我认为只是，你知道，对自己好一点，慢慢来，休息一下，不要在上面做太多工作，找四个人，也许最多四个人，看看你信任的人，
that you trust people that you know um be aware of too much social media but also too little it can be useful it can be helpful but get the amount of it right um pat yourself on the back and give you a cuddle like before i applied i would have loved to meet people who got on first time. And actually, I'd love to have conversations with people who got on three or four times. I'd love to hear about them as a personality. Yeah, just honestly, just, yeah. Incredible.
你认识的人。注意不要过度使用社交媒体，但也不要太少。它可能是有用的，可能有帮助的，但要把握好度。拍拍自己的背，给自己一个拥抱。在我申请之前，我很想见到那些一次就成功的人。实际上，我很想和那些申请了三四次才成功的人交谈。我很想听听他们作为个性的故事。是的，真的，只是，是的。不可思议。
Just, yeah, just empower people to do what's authentic to them i'm really sorry but we are going to have to go because otherwise my kids are going to be uh put into wraparound child care but it's been the biggest privilege to speak to you and i feel like i can invite you back on for many many future episodes but wishing you the loveliest time on training there will be hard days you know you may even fail another assignment and that's okay it's it's all part of the process and many of us do i definitely failed one so um just be kind to yourself support yourself look after yourself really enjoy this summer as well you know i think it's a very special summer indeed where you're about to start your training
只是，是的，只是赋予人们做真实自我的力量。我真的很抱歉，但我们必须走了，否则我的孩子们就要被送到全日制托儿所了，但能和你交谈是最大的荣幸，我觉得我可以邀请你回来参加许多许多未来的剧集，但祝你在培训中度过最美好的时光。会有艰难的日子，你知道，你甚至可能挂掉另一门作业，那没关系，这是过程的一部分，我们很多人都经历过。我绝对挂过一门，所以，嗯，对自己好一点，支持自己，照顾好自己，也真正享受这个夏天，你知道，我认为这是一个非常特别的夏天，你即将开始你的培训，
enjoy your family life enjoy not having any academic work to submit. Definitely. I'm going to take a break, give you a bit of a rest before it all costs the kickoff again. But best wishes to everybody listening and thinking about applying for next year. Really, really good luck.
享受你的家庭生活，享受没有任何学术作业要提交的时光。绝对的。我要休息一下，在一切重新开始之前让你休息一下。但祝所有正在收听并考虑明年申请的人好运。真的，真的祝你好运。
Take care. And thanks, Mariam. Appreciate it. Thank you so much for your time. Thank you. Well, I am now back from the school run and i've also been to the supermarket to get some mushrooms and some bread but it is the same day that i spoke to mark and it was such a pleasure to speak to him um i'm sorry we didn't have a chance to properly
保重。谢谢你，玛丽安（Mariam）。很感激。非常感谢你的时间。谢谢。好吧，我现在从接孩子放学回来了，我也去了超市买了些蘑菇和面包，但这是我和马克交谈的同一天，和他交谈真是太愉快了。嗯，我很抱歉我们没有机会适当地
finish the episode as mindfully as i might have enjoyed but I did send him some voice notes with quite profusive thank yous so yeah I hope you found that really interesting if you have your own unique stories to tell that you think people in this audience of aspiring psychologists might well gain or learn something from then do please get in contact with me and let's see if we can sort out getting you on the podcast if you would welcome some more guided help and support to support your career aspirations, then do check out the Aspiring Psychologist membership. There's more information about that in the show notes or you can get it by clicking on any of the links in my social media bios. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. Thank you so much for being part of my world.
像我可能希望的那样专注地结束这一集，但我确实给他发了一些语音笔记，表达了非常深切的感谢。所以，是的，我希望你觉得这非常有趣。如果你有自己独特的故事要讲，你认为这个有抱负的心理学家听众群体可能会从中获得或学到一些东西，那么请务必与我联系，让我们看看能否安排你上播客。如果你欢迎更多指导性的帮助和支持来支持你的职业抱负，那么请查看“有抱负的心理学家会员资格”（Aspiring Psychologist membership）。关于这一点，节目说明中有更多信息，或者你可以通过点击我社交媒体简介中的任何链接来获取。我到处都是玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。
We will have some compassionate Q&As coming up to support the next application season. I will find some space in my diary and communicate those dates to you as soon as I can. Be kind to yourselves and I'll look forward to catching up with you for the next episode, which is available for you from 6 a.m. on Monday. Take care. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast
我们将会有一些富有同情心的问答环节，以支持下一个申请季。我会从我的日程表中找些时间，并尽快将这些日期传达给你。善待自己，我期待在下一集中与你相见，该集将于周一上午6点为你提供。保重。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在你身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》
With Dr. Marianne Trent my name is Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
与玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）一起。我叫贾娜（Jana），我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。这让我感到惊讶，原来有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，而且没有完美的成为心理学家的方法。这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。